it's time for the potato harvest in vine
out two hours drive from Berlin
vegetables belonging to city dwellers
grow and ripen on IP Gardens half
hectare of land that's right
IP Internet Protocol garden urbanites
can farm crops here without ever having
to set foot on the sandy soil gardeners
on location take care of the dirty work
each online farmer rents a 16 square
meter plot for a euro a day the would-be
Internet farmers can choose from a
variety of crops from lettuce to flowers
I used to cultivate a plot of land with
my family but the problem was that we
couldn't water it during the week we
were in the city and only got out there
on weekends then on the internet I came
across the farmville simulation game
where you plant in water and so on and I
knew I had to turn it into reality
reality IP garden provides its remote
farmers with a massive data once a week
a drone even supplies aerial pictures it
gives users an overview of the state of
their crops closed-circuit TV guards the
farmer on the clock and each of the 56
individual plots is equipped with
sensors the measuring devices register
moisture levels in the soil exposure to
sunlight and air pressure
the data is transmitted via bluetooth to
a computer which collates the
information and puts it online
they got nothing Sam hi mr. Gartner is
sitting at his home computer and needs
to get his plants enough water these
parameters help him decide whether the
soil is moist enough how high is the
electrical conductivity what's the
coefficient and how are my plants
looking using my new friends knows these
seventh grade students at the Platonists
school in Berlin's panco district also
want to know how their gardens doing
they've rented an IP garden plot each
student has been growing their favorite
vegetable on a 1 meter square allotment
they can call up the data on IP Gardens
online platform and water their patch
with a mouse click the program also
tells you if you've had an infestation
things like beetles snails whatever and
that way you know what you have to do
especially in the city not everyone has
got a garden where they can do something
like this so being able to do it online
is really practical the classes IP
garden project is part of its science
work and technology curriculum today's
lesson is about plants the students are
learning which types of vegetables are
best planted next to each other how can
I feed myself properly without harming
or being unfair to others for instance
in Africa or other places how can I feed
myself without damaging other people or
the environment that's the message we
want to convey here but first you have
to get your crop going not so easy via
the Internet
that's attack I basically thought it
would be dead easy I sit at my computer
and press the water button or whatever
but now I know that some plants aren't
compatible my plant isn't compatible
with cabbages and eggplants and because
yellow tomatoes need some support out in
the field via app she informs the
gardener he can see the tasks he has to
perform on each square meter
today it's fertilizing using a brew of
stinging nettles decided digitally
carried out on location practical
attractive but a concept that also has
detractors when you put forward the IP
garden principle you often hear I'd
rather have my kids dig around in the
soil themselves fact is though that
neither they nor their kids actually go
digging it's a longing that's often not
realized so in that sense the IP garden
is a very good and sensible alternative
it certainly is a healthy alternative
the online farmers can pick up their
crop or have it delivered the surplus is
donated to a Berlin homeless charity